good to see you how are you hi i'm good
thank you how are you
i'm doing well so as far as secrets go
and big twists in the mcu this ranks up
there
as one of the most people are going to
be talking about this for years to come
how do you feel about you being involved
in something that's
such a huge twist for the mcu oh it
feels great it's
uh it's interesting it's fun i mean you
know it's fun to be uh
it's fun to be a secret it's fun to have
to reveal it to surprise people
it's uh i think you know i love to be
surprised
so i so it's it's good to do it to
to the others um and so yeah the
character is so cool i'm just i'm just
thrilled to be part of it
who got to know in your life like who
got to know what this was and had to
also keep this a secret for this long
well no one i was i was saying even my
mother only found out about this two
days ago
and she a year ago when the movie was
supposed to come out she
she saw the trailer and she said oh i
saw this cool trailer of a film
it's called black widow uh let's go and
watch it i said sure i'll take you
we'll go and i didn't say anything
um yeah my son has seen me in costume
but he's very young so he had no idea
what that character he could never even
spill it out because he he didn't i
never told him the name so
who as far as he was concerned mommy was
just a superhero
and that's all what was your first
thought your first reaction
when you found out the arc of this
character uh
no it was uh it was cool i mean the
thing is there's only that much that
you know you can uh you can show uh
the back the background of the character
um
and um you know a lot of it we we
spoke through with kate uh you know
about it
and we we came up with uh
well we've even more i had to come up
with a with a
with a back story uh for even you know
more complex than what you see on screen
and uh
the character is very uh is very damaged
i mean there is a there is a she's a
killing machine but underneath it's
there is a human being and
human being who endured a lot in her you
know in her childhood and you know who
who has this uh horrible physical trauma
and um clearly we understand has been
you know traumatized uh
mentally and emotionally and is
manipulated
and so the
my feeling is the more the more complex
the character is the more it's fun for
me to play with it because there's so
much to her she's not just black and
white she's uh
there's a combination of good and evil
in her and it could be explored and it
could go in
all sorts of directions it's there is a
lot to play with
what was it like for you playing the
moment when she wakes up
so to speak it was a great moment i
think it's uh
um it was uh it felt beautiful because
this is where here
her you know her heart gets awake and
her soul
is present for a glimpse of it and
and it's always it's this mystery you
know that suddenly
coming you know that
is breaking around her and you see that
there's just this
um you know the this human being and
this
this little girl who never got got to
grow up who never had a proper childhood
probably
um and um and that moment where the
you know to the two women just come head
to head like that
there is this acceptance and realization
that we are
we are we are
made from the same we are
you know related pro where we're sisters
we're this
we are you know we have to be together
instead of being against each other
and there's this peace and it's just
beautiful
a beautiful glimpse yeah beautiful
moment yeah
it's a fantastic moment thank you so
much for this time
enjoy the rest of your day
you